et le gouvernement le goût on en parlait
depuis hier en fait a choisi de nous
aussi un répit aux québécois alors qu'en
est il de la situation mon invité
christine goût et président de l'ordre
des psychologues du québec bonsoir
doctor who bienvenue à 24,60 ya le
premier de ce trou d'eau à esker en
déclarant une chose comme celle là c'est
une façon d'être
empathique de tendre la main de
comprendre qu'est ce qu'on en voit comme
un signal et en même temps le signal de
monsieur legault hier moi j'ai ma mère
de 91 ans le j'ai besoin de la voir j'ai
besoin de vos messages oui tout à fait
je pense que il ya pas un décideur qui
ne qui n'est pas sympathique et la
situation parce que ce sont des êtres
humains qui évidemment sont dans la même
situation
alors donc je pense que tout le monde
est sensible à cette difficulté là
d'avoir des restrictions par rapport au
contact humain au contact de nos proches
alors l'impact de savoir qu'on pouvoir
avoir un répit à noël de quelques jours
qu'elle est il selon vous mais c'est sûr
que les traditions c'est quelque chose
d'important au niveau de l'identité
c'est quelque chose d'important au
niveau de la sécurité parce que c'est
une chose qui est stable dans la vie
alors que en général la vie change
donc c'est certain que puis une des
traditions du temps des feuilles par
c'est justement de se réunir puis de
voir la famille qu'on n'a pas le quart
de ces serments de voir souvent par
ailleurs et on sait que évidement
l'ellipse qu'aux souligné aptitudes d'un
facteur de protection aussi pour la
santé mentale donc c'est évident que ça
va faire du bien à tout le monde je
pense particulièrement dans ces périodes
là sauf exception parce qu'il ya quand
même certaines personnes qui n'aiment
pas la période de noël et qui soit pour
des tensions familiales ou soit pour des
raisons de deux solitudes choisi préfère
éviter les
les rencontres de familles de la
majorité des gens souhaitent donc
pouvoir se réunir et je vous dirais
probablement particulièrement
les jeunes enfants particulièrement les
gens plus âgés aussi ils sont un petit
peu plus et se lit donc si je pense que
ça va être perçu comme étant une très
couru en même temps est un risque à
prendre notamment entre les petits
enfants et les grands parents
est ce que ça ne génère pas aussi un peu
beaucoup d'anxiété dans certains cas
dans la prise de décision dans la
préparation de ces rencontres
je pense qu'on se retrouve dans une
situation saine à log à celle de l'été
dernier la différence et dernier on
n'est qu'à l'extérieur
non mais la décision devait se rendre au
camp iv par exemple les failles
d'anniversaire ou ce qui est compliqué
ici c'est que dans le fond il faut
regarder le risque pour la santé
physique
le risque étant la probabilité quelque
chose arrive pour garder danger en
danger qui est la conséquence si ça
arrive puis les séquelles potentielles
il le problème quand il faut le regarder
pour la santé physique mais il faut le
regarder pour la santé mentale
ce qui est compliqué ici c'est qu'on
peut pour le regarder au cas par cas et
c'est ça qui est complexe et que il faut
les regarder dans une perspective de
deux coups le plus grand intérêt du plus
grand nombre qui dans une perspective
conséquentialiste selon qui il faut
essayer d'envisager les conséquences de
nos actions
alors il ya une part de jugement qui
doit servir par exemple est-ce qu'on a
des personnes vulnérables à protéger
puis si par exemple on m gr maman 96 ans
qu'ils élucident pitié à voir son monde
qui fait le choix de les voir qui sait
pas combien relevé ce domaine c'est très
différent que une autre personne par
exemplaire vendu risque pour la santé de
cette personne mais il y aura alors je
pense une somme de facteurs à considérer
c'est facile de faire des balises
uniforme je pense que la décision qui
était pliée sperme et rippy justement en
minimisant le risque pour la majorité
des gens parce que ça permet justement
de penser la fin des vacances en dans
une forme de parenthèse si vous voulez
l'idée de présenter un contrat moral aux
citoyens de les engager
comment évaluez vous cette proposition
mais je pense que chaque citoyen un
contrat moral avec sa culture et avec sa
société de toute façon c'est à dire que
à moins d'être un être complètement
chacun des citoyens aux déjà un
engagement moral c'est à dire que la
raison pour laquelle on a été compliqué
au printemps la raison pour laquelle on
fait attention membres de notre famille
la raison pour laquelle on porte le
masque quand on voit dans les lieux
publics les c'est parce que justement on
9 ce contrat moral par rapport aux
autres
je pense qu'il faut le rappeler parce
que le fait le con tre bras il faut
qu'ils soient resserrées un peu et
absolue dans une dans une société on
parle souvent d'une courbe normale ce
que des gens qui ont des très grandes
feuilles que des gens qui en ont moins
et on va voir de l'extrême de beauté de
l'ex imam de l'opération
on souhaite c'est que les gens soient qu
le plus les plus cohésive possible dans
le plus grand intérêt du plus rarement
d'individus fait méfiance parce que
c'est une période difficile et que
l'hiver et période plus difficile que le
pays voulait déjà très confus le premier
sera évoquée dans l'extrait qu'on en a
présenté juste avant notre entretien
puis je m'entretiens dans un instant
avec alexis ii lancèrent l'animateur
données sur les décrypteurs c'est que
les théories du complot ou l'intérêt
qu'on leur porte soit augmentée va
exponentielle un peu comme la pandémie
vous voyez le lien
dimensions psychologiques importantes à
l'adhésion
ces théories une dimension psychologique
extrêmement important parce que quand on
adhère à la théorie du complot sait déjà
qu'on se radicalise donc c'est une forme
de radicalisation
on perd une certaine forme de sens
critique si vous voulez et là tout les
éléments qui nous permettent d'infirmer
cette théorie du complot servent à la
confirmer c'est à dire que ça fait
partie du complot lui-même mais alors si
c'est pas nécessairement un signe que la
pensée de la personne se porte bien
c'est pas nécessairement le signe que
c'est quand les gens perdent leur sens
critique qui perd de recul qui perdent
le sens de la nuance est qui qui qui se
radicalisent dans une forme de pensée
c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas un
symptôme de bonne santé psychologique
menée 6 1 surtout dans le déni de
l'existence même de la commune en
terminant je sens quelques secondes
parce qu'on en avait parlé
l'annoncé récente du gouvernement
d'investir des millions en santé mentale
et de donner accès aux soins puisque le
gic est ce que vous avez vu une
différence déjà sur le terrain il est
trop tôt en principe un espace pour
organiser tout cela non c'est encore
récente
mais il ya quand même une volonté et je
pense que et je pense qu'actuellement la
santé mentale et arty et préoccupations
de nos espérons qu'on vende changements
rapidement pour la période des fêtes est
une source de détresse naturellement
pour les gens qui n'ont rien qui peuvent
passer les briques son élection devenu
pas où il ya déjà qu'ils sont tombés ce
seuil de la pauvreté depuis le début ça
parle de cette pandémie et qui se
sentent au bord du précipice alors
espérons qu'il y aura des changements
pour les fêtes
absolument parce que de villepin de
suite face au monde et il faut saluer
opposés et un facteur grand merci au
revoir au revoir